m
une vingtaine d'années auront suffi à
lhasa de sela pour marquer profondément
la scène musicale québécoise
c'est incroyable l'impact que cette
femme a eu sur tant de gens de plusieurs
pays lhasa de sela a une vie hors du
commun son imaginaire riche a été forgé
par une enfance passée sur la route vous
trois heures
d'une part on peut inviter dans un
autobus voyage unique au début des
années 90 elle s'installe à montréal où
étudie ses seins elle y rencontre le
musicien yves desrosiers qui l'aident à
trouver sa voie
puis nasa commencèrent commencé c'est
plus facile parce qu'on est mutuellement
de trouver ce que moi aussi si ce mode
on était en pleine grogne dans 94 des
grands champs puis nous on arrive à sa
chanson
[Musique]
la sas une ensorceleuse j'ai pu voir un
peu quand même l'effet qu'elle avait
sonné gens à les ensorcelés et le charme
opère
son premier album est un immense succès
ça a été vraiment un coup de foudre
réciproque entre une chanteuse qui
découvre son public est un public qui
fait comme vous et bruits chante chante
quand on aime ce une renommée bientôt
internationale ces trois albums se sont
écoulés à plus de 500000 exemplaires
puis en 2010 la maladie fera après 21
mois de lutte elle succombe à un cancer
du sein elle avait 37 ans on croyait pas
qu'elle allait mourir personnes
croyaient qu'elle allait mourir ça
semblait impossible elle même avait une
confiance dans son sa pérennité ou sa
résilience à toute épreuve
mais son souvenir reste bien vivant en
témoignent de nombreux concerts hommages
une biographie hymne un peu par que
montréal est nommé en son honneur
la ce a eu une grande influence sur les
artistes montréalais
c'est pas juste du domaine de l'esprit
meermans du corps et de l'âme
[Musique]
à
elle continue d'inspirer le spectacle le
temps cela ça danse basée sur ses
chansons sera représentée l'automne
prochain à la place des arts est au
zénith de saint eustache permettant à
ses mots et à son âme de continuer à
raisonner sur scène et dans les coeurs
mon père m'a dit une fois qu'ils se
parlent pas de la vie et la mort ça
m'intéresse pas messina by alexandre
charti radio canada montréal